okay let's see if we can finish it where
did we get up to last time
oh no i just remembered it got
flashbacks
oh i screamed so much last time it was
the scariest oh my
ah god so
oh why am i playing with a keyboard and
i can just play with my controller right
oh but we do have a super cool hat
though
yeah because i remember guys you
remember this we could um
play fetch with the monster
because then the monster would the
monster's gone
the monster oh my god
i was not not ready for that uh
anyway i just wanted to play ball with
them
pick up the ball pick up
this is the game now like we're gonna
stay here forever
five seconds in really
i love it i love it so much right bye
mantas
we're gonna progress in the game we
can't just play fetch the whole time
and be scared by hands um
so she used this once to open the door
so i can take this one back out now
because we're
lucky
to make some progress
oh she's going to get the other one
what a cute little support character
jack dw frost was not ready for that
scream no
neither was i uh can you help me
i need to get up there can you help me
please
oh yeah i can do this
hi nevermind i got it
i don't need you
i will protect you protract you
although i wonder if i die at the end of
this
because this is uh most definitely a
prequel to the first game right
and uh oh oh my god this brings you back
to a recurring nightmare i had when i
was a kid oh jesus
i i used to have this nightmare when i
was a kid
i would be in a big room
with my class okay in primary school so
all my friends and my classmates and my
teachers and whatever
and then for some reason i would leave
the room i would be like asked to leave
the room or i need to go to the toilet
or something i'd leave the room
and i'd come out into a hallway just
like this
and i would look back to the door where
i came and i could see a little window
and i could see
all my classmates and my teachers in
this brightly lit room having fun
and i couldn't open the door again and i
was pounding on it
and then i could hear like squealing of
uh wheels and footsteps
and i would look down the corridor and
there's nothing there and it's just
really dark
but i could hear it coming closer and
closer to my corridor
and then i would just see these feet
dead feet with um
the little label come around the corner
and then i would always wake up like
before i would see the rest of the body
on there
oh freaky
but anyway yeah it's reminding me of
that
oh no
[Music]
scary story pig
you calling me a pig that's not very
nice
i like the fact as well that it's very
um i guess realistic in the sense of
like
your flashlight uh you have to turn it
off if you want to do anything like if i
want to grab on to anything
or use pallet pellet switch or something
i have to turn it off whereas in some
games they'll just clip it onto the
character right and just be on all the
time
something's gonna happen here
wait is that oh there
here get it get it get it get it [ __ ]
nope nope
let's get it away all right come over
here handy
candy yes leave leave
oh scheizer i just uh
i jumped on it didn't mean to do that
next time i'm gonna go straight to the
weapon
okay straight to the weapon please here
between two porsches where did that hand
come from
where is it here it is
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you hand sorry
try not to swear it just i really can't
not swear especially when i'm playing a
horror game
[Music]
this is mental
[Music]
i don't know how it cracks its own
knuckles it needs another hand to crack
its knuckles for it
oh that would be so cool wouldn't it if
there was more than one hand and then
they
they got together to crack each other's
knuckles and then they went apart again
oh they missed out there didn't they
okay i'll help you
oh i can't take this with me
oh there's the um the face the face
masks
there's something here
[Music]
how big is this thing i'm not i don't
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
what's he doing
what is he supposed to be like some sort
of caterpillar
what's he attached to
he's crawling on the ceiling how is he
defying gravity like that
i mean he doesn't exactly look polite
oh my god he's near me
it's okay we'll wait for him to get back
in the middle of there yeah
it's our chance come on let's go
[Music]
um
i'll wait for him to go back on the
ceiling
is he spiderman uh
yeah this is spiderman if he lets
himself go a little bit
[Music]
yes
uh hello mr man
oh creepy
where am i heading towards
i have to press that button
or is there something down here oh oh
right
i need a box let's press the button
of course you can't play game why you do
[Music]
this
oh no that's so difficult i can't bloody
say oh game
okay
i need
smoking
we gotta go
come on
boom baby
where did renko go
oh my god
how did he not get me for so long i
absolutely must have gone the wrong way
or something
i think i'm supposed to uh hide when i
get in there
oh oh sax how how did it not
hear that right come on
[Music]
let's go hide
oh sorry fine okay i gotta hide
outside the door i'm guessing
where she's hiding follow her
maybe you get locks in there
spooky spooky
oh i went into the wall i was reading
the messages
okay now we make a
hey minimum
but he can deadlift 500
kilograms
i mean if he can carry his whole weight
around all day every day
he's got some gigantic muscles maybe
that's not you know
what you guys are thinking is flab
that's just one
gigantic muscle
i see the little lie flashing that means
spooky things save
time
yeah maybe he's like he's like one of
those people that lost a lot of weight
so it's just that's why it's like a
little bit flabby because he just lost a
lot of weight but now he's like
hinch
hello hello
dead people
it's weird
hold on let me just look around first
ah padlocked
oh apparently there's a hat around
somewhere
okay i'll keep an eye out for hats
lad where would the hat be
maybe it's in the other room
i mean i can't imagine it'll be on any
of these bodies
no i think it's gonna be in the other
room let's go
oh i'm stuck where am i
there's the key but where's the hat
though
hat are you in here
uh i don't know why i just did that
because i can't can i climb up these
how did i do that
jump there i could open you
spooky toes not a fan of feet
can i climb up here i'm gonna go up the
table
hmm
cannot just jump off that onto the table
oh no because this oh i see
i see
i'm an angry bear
okay let's jump over here
see i like this little chopping board
telling me where i can jump off from
helping me with my issues with the 2.5 d
world where is the hat
i have not found any hat
very disappointed
uh
[Music]
wait oh chizu ochi
zuki san wants to see my hats that's the
hat
i don't think i've been doing very good
in my hat collection really
i think i must have i must have missed a
lot of
hats
not very good but i can't see a hat
here
nikki said i was warm
i don't know where i could be
i can't see anything
your fave is the yellow one and the
other one what's the other one
i don't know where the heart is
it's not up there is it because there's
nothing up there
see nikki there's lag so when you when
you say hot
i'm probably super cold like by the time
i read it
um
i don't know you could just tell me if
you wanted to at this point
i'm probably doing a dum dum
doing the dum dum
it's not like around here or anything is
it
there's a sponge
to the left of the table in the back
like on the floor or on the table
oh i can open this one
oh thanks guys thank you for the help i
would i wouldn't have found that
let's have a look oh
mommy hi i think i still prefer my um
teddy bear hat though
what do you think teddy bear yellow what
what ha we'll wear this for a little bit
what's your favorite hat let's have a
hat vote i want to know what's your
favorite hat
should i get back in here to get back
out
no no no i'm not in there
don't leave me alone with these dead
people
please thank you
sidney likes the box just you know your
basic box
the box that comes with the default
it is cute
okay so we have the key now
i thought i dropped it and forgotten to
take it with me for a second
oh god
yeah i think um if i were to play this
again i would literally scour every
corner
to try and find the the hats because
they
they've hidden them in some quite good
places in the hats
they're not like every other horror game
where it's got like an emissive on it
and it's shining like
choose me choose me pick me a lot of
them
they make sense in the environment that
they're in and because of that they're
easily overlooked so
it's i actually i think it's good i like
it it's a nice collectible
it makes you feel good when you find one
don't be dub dubs this way
[Music]
oh balls oh i thought it died then
the full damage well there's hardly any
ball damage
very lucky
okay so my question is is there like a
gap here no i don't think there is
you can
i'm angry
he doesn't care
see he's fine everything's fine
oh there it is
big caterpillar
big caterpillar
what are you doing
thanksgiving with malachi you say
handstand and silk
queen out of it again oh
i miss ah i miss silks i can't wait to
get back to aerial classes once period
is over
okay so wait can you can you get me up
there
oh yes oh no again
quick hurry
what do we have here
that didn't seem human
i want to look behind it oh it's so
crazy
i love it i'm gonna go
switch how do i do this
i'm sure i'll get to eventually can i
hello
hello can i jump
hello
ah
wait can i pull the plug
i can't reach it
there's nothing else here that i can use
to stand up
i must be able to come back and help out
because uh yes i would pull the plug
without a doubt i would
well actually because what if it's just
being nursed back to health
i can't see that happening in this game
but it is a possibility you know
and that would suck
oh i have to i have to
oh god oh god
[Music]
oh my god
uh
okay
[Music]
oh no
[Music]
what the hell am i supposed to do now
[Music]
hello
hello i'm just like
what am i doing
what nikki said it glitched
oh no did i make the game
something went wrong
okay let's restart let's kill this guy
again
you guys some
let's morbid what was supposed to happen
i did notice this um piece of the ladder
falling so you couldn't get back
up there nice little detail
ggs
oh
fine you know i did that on purpose
making you guys wait a little bit longer
suspense and all that not that you uh
i haven't already seen what's gonna
happen or anything but
here we go
uh
oh come on get up the dead person's legs
go
stop it let's go
ain't no time let the present come on
let's go
i don't know how i didn't see me calling
i'm not gonna ask i'm just gonna go
come on
why is she so slow
she's down here hold my hand come on
we're going together hold my hand
stay here oh wait sit here
oh [ __ ] now what
maybe i go backwards but where am i
supposed to go backwards oh
oh okay now you go first okay i see you
let's go oh my god why are you sneaking
i think i held the crouch button for too
long because you if you cross your mind
you slide
and i guess if you hold it for too long
and you end up crouching after you
finish
[Music]
all right come on let's go
no stop
i was finding that i just died the game
was like oh she survived but she's not
supposed to be here
let's just kill her yes
come on i don't like the slide thing
i'm not gonna do it i have to do it
cause i even if i just tap it
it just ends up bloody crouching
how do i stop it going into a crouch
after i slide
let's let's just practice this
do i press it twice no it's still
crouching
oh this is so annoying
you literally default to crouching to
get back
up from the slide that's so annoying
how like even when i like
slide crouch and then i'm pressing x it
there is like a second delay
to being able to get up out of that
crouch into a jump oh
that's infuriating okay whatever
[Applause]
[Music]
okay did it once do it again
fine i'll take it
oh come on
glad i didn't have a top on it
mine
[Music]
what
she doesn't go
oh wait maybe we block him in okay yeah
i'll go with you
what happens now do we just watch him
hello sir please go into a big
gaping hole
hello sir
i think i brought look at him again he
doesn't know where we
are but he cannot progress
in his animations
ah come on in there
oh yes i see
i was on the right lines let's do it
come on
[Music]
she's like oh lovely nice and tasty yes
they're romantic
is it is it good
i just wanted to sit by the fire i got
too close
now we can sit in the games like this is
how you sit by a fire
[Music]
sensibly
[Music]
let's throw the shoe in the fire
what it went through the door i guess
that technically went
into the fire
can we go back ah it's all blocked off
columbine is fire bad but it's so pretty
though
okay uh all right she's gonna give me a
boost
thank you very
we're much now
[Music]
i think we're
[Music]
coming out of the hospital oh i think i
hear a tv
are we gonna get to the end of that
weird ass hallway
[Music]
let's get a can of sprite
is sprite like a global drink or is that
oh come on you can't light that vending
machine
and not give me something
maybe i can pick something up and chuck
it at it
and then i can get my kind of sprite
here we go
oh iron brew oh i am rude
no kidding me
[Music]
[Music]
of all the choices sprites honestly
actually i don't like fizzy drinks
but actually no i like vipto and
i am fruit i do like iron brown but i i
don't like coconut
yeah and i hate like lemon or orange
flavored things
so not a fan of like orange tango
lemonade so i don't know why i said
sprite
i like cherry tango
vinto is good
oh why am i closing the door i need to
open it
i'm bruce great i remember i went to
scotland once and i was like yes because
in scotland like coca-cola iron brew is
their coca-cola so if you go to like
i don't know a shop or something like if
you if you go to the
mcdonald's or something they'll be like
do you want coke with that
there's a stew and i agree with that i
was like
wow
[Music]
no see that's the i like how i like
actual oranges i like orange juice
but i don't like orange flavored things
just the orange flavoring itself like
the artificial orange flavor
don't like that tell you what
flavor i love i love artificial banana
so good artificial balance i
love banana i just love bananas anyway
stop talking about the flavors of drinks
looks like a head in the bin i think
this game is quite good at that
showing you just enough to make your
imagination kind of fill in the blanks
what's that
why aren't people just taking off their
onesies
in the street and just leaving them on
the benches
so weird
is that a person
that's a person
okay so these are people they're not
birds falling
okay uh okay right
some big birds i don't know genetic
mutation
oh gosh
uh someone having a party
[Music]
i don't know where he went but i wasn't
looking
did he just ram his head are they
committing suicide on purpose
something's making them commit suicide
she's kicking him is he dead
yes
see i'm not the only one who was into
the party
it's all right sir i can dance with you
you want a dance partner i can dance
with you
you want to dance
[Music]
should i touch it
i'll leave
okay you enjoy your program there
[Music]
lady
[Music]
that's dangerous stop that
you're going to endanger yourself stop
[Music]
[Music]
it
this is the tv like brainwashing
everybody
to kill themselves or start eating other
people
i'm coming oh that was close
they're watching your streams i don't
stream that often nikki
or maybe that's why they do it they're
like she's only on like once in a blue
moon we must watch
oh no it's locked what are we gonna do
what are we gonna do with this it's
locked
do you have any ideas i i always come up
with the solutions
i want some teamwork here actually you
did do something
oh yeah you've got the other light for
me what are we gonna do about this
[Music]
oh i see
there was a i could climb up the top
there
[Music]
oh
hopefully i'll spawn yes back up here
[Music]
oh but how am i supposed to get here
i should just climb up the road okay
unless i can jump off like is she
dancing no she's telling me to go
i thought she was dancing to the music
yeah we can jump out okay
bye
wait am i marioing this
how am i supposed to do this
haha we are marrying it
i'm glad you like my jump malachi
yahoo
don't worry i'll find a key
that was easy
any hats any hats
this drawing of those pyramid things
it's a mug
no hats let's get the key then get the
key key
please may i have lift
thank you
what did that do is that gonna make this
go up up higher
you do you think she's not coming in so
maybe not
i don't know what else it would have
done laughs screw it i'm going to try it
come on
i was wrong
oh it's gone back up so let's do this
again
nothing else in this room
this box
hmm
[Music]
okay this is weird
but there's no obvious
way to go with this switch
this opens a tiny bit
[Music]
i'm not sure what else to do here
i really don't feel like there's
anything i can do in this room at least
but then there's nothing else up here so
maybe i do have to go down
you're gonna give me any tips
you're standing by the elevator
nikki said this part is not explained at
all by the way which
doesn't fill me with confidence
but okay
maybe i'll just go back down again
maybe
[Music]
oh ah what the hell
but i don't see how anything in here
could change just from
flipping that switch so i don't really
know why i would be
going back down
[Music]
y'all
why what do you do switch like what is
your purpose
it doesn't do anything
and that elevator will just go back down
[Music]
again
i can't remember arkham knight's
elevator apostle
so long ago
there's something else to do in the
elevator apart from go back down again
it does something but what does it do
it looks like it starts to build up
nothing happened
apparently i had it before so
sorry sometimes the game just pauses so
i do
just jump
but why am i jumping oh god not like
that oh
idiot
i just don't get how that would change
anything like it doesn't make any
logical sense because nothing in that
little
cupboard bit can be changed
i'm getting tired now how close am i to
the end because i'm probably gonna have
to
go soon
today is thursday and trillion today is
thursday
thursday is today
yep
i still got quite a way i think i'm
gonna have to
finish it soon then and then uh
i'll finish it next week i thought this
would be the end
but this is a lot longer than the first
game
not complaining not complaining at all
i mean we already we defeated
a caterpillar monster a caterpillar man
very muscly caterpillar man
wait how are you here what the hell how
are you here
explain how are you here what
what is this how did
this scenario happen
what what
how did you do this who are you who do
you work for
the game showed me what i had to do
because i was struggling okay i gotta
give props props to you game that that
was good that was good
you knew you knew that some people would
take a long time some people like me
and that's the outcome night puzzle got
it
got it got it
okay so let's do this gotta time it it
seems to be quite quick
if she gets in my way i'm gonna be one
unhappy girl
tough jump
oh this game is so pretty it's a tv
signal it's the tv's like not for evil
tv
no
this is so cinematic so cool
over here
secrets wait no this is where i'm
playing from not mine
maybe i can find this
never mind
monkeys
monkeys monkeys
now i am the kids
oh
hello
come on i'll keep it open for you
oh i didn't mean to smash your head with
it sorry come on let's go
did she not come because of the box
thanks lovely view for following
oh my god i think i'm stuck
i can't pull this box or push it
the other one
i don't know for some reason she doesn't
want to come in and
nothing really seems to be going on here
anyways
yeah i think that's supposed to be a
bird it's weird
okay so what we're doing then if you're
not gonna go in there
then what would you like to do
wow the game is going flat
am i supposed to do something with this
box
can't take it outside
what do you want to do
oh apparently this isn't the way it's
just for the glitch kid
i don't see where else i'm supposed to
go
and maybe i can get up there
[Music]
ah maybe i can get up there
forgot how good a timer he was
thank you we merge into one
but we're together
oh nearly
come on you got this there you go see
even the npc's miss sometimes guys
not just me or you
although you probably don't do as bad as
i do
oh no okay to be fair
i'm not gonna say it
yeah to be fair i haven't missed one of
these jumps
yeah but i didn't want to jinx it
i'm just looking at the chat and i can
just see sam jones saying
i love the movie up don't you nikki
thanks guys give me a little bit
find the dream
okay i i really do need to go to because
i have quite a busy day tomorrow
this place is falling
no no no come on
okay okay
she's so fast
uh i jumped though
are you okay
you okay let me hand
you okay you okay you okay you okay look
you can move you can move
does anything hurt look there's a mitten
you want this mitten
oh it's not missing what is this i
thought i was holding a mitten
oh it's nothing
okay i should stop here for tonight
and then i will be back and i will
actually finish the game
next week so i'm guessing
there's there's gonna be at least one
more scary bad guy
that i have to come across so excited
for that
yay but thank you so much for spending
the evening with me
it's been a pleasure as always
good fun uh i don't know what we're
gonna play after a little nightmares but
we'll see we'll see i have a few games
that i'd be wanting to play so
maybe i'll do another poll and see what
you guys think
um but yeah thanks so much for watching
i will see you again
this time next thursday well 8
30 p.m gmt is when it starts
every thursday so i'll see you next
thursday